l'acquis note de samsung vient à
l'instant de se terminer pour présenter
ces deux nouveaux téléphones le samsung
galaxy et suites et samsung galaxy et
suit plus
en réalité s'agit plus que de deux
nouveaux téléphones mais vraiment d'un
écosystème samsung qui s'avérait juste
dingue
alors on connaissait déjà plein de
choses ils étaient les samsung on
connaissait les frigos samsung
reconnaissait les téléphones les
tablettes mais là on est quand même
plein de nouveautés et c'est ainsi
vraiment intéressant parce que ça
démontre vraiment des recourants valeurs
tmt technologie et vers quoi on va au
niveau du futur aux dioula doux et
technologie le téléphone on en avait
déjà parlé d'ordures laisse un écran qui
va jusque sur les côtés tu vois pas de
bordures en écran arrondi beaucoup plus
de place pour pouvoir effectivement
avoir plus de zones de contact c'est le
tout premier téléphone avec autant zone
de contact par rapport à la taille du
téléphone c'est vraiment hyper
intéressante la présentation était a été
fait de même m d'abord c'est dj coq il
l'a fait et ensuite avec vraiment toute
la team la grande t-il samsung qui était
là pour présenter ce produit en grandes
pompes et c'était vraiment hyper bien
fait très bien ficelé et encore une
superbe leçon de présentation jacques à
quatre pour accueillir sept pilotes
le premier point c'est le galaxy s suite
et elle suit plus de nouveaux téléphones
dont j'ai parlé à l'instant ils sont
super intéressant le deuxième point
c'est big bih c'est la nouvelle
intelligence artificielle de samsung
c'est un peu le ciridd samsung si tu
veux pour la faire un petit peu simple
simpliste même parce que en réalité
bixby promet beaucoup de choses et je
vais t'expliquer sahara est vraiment
super intéressant le troisième point
c'est la nouvelle caméra à 360 degrés de
samsung est beaucoup plus simple en cape
iv tu vas voir on rend pas reine en
quelques instants et le quatrième point
c'est samsung d'aix d'excès nouvel
ordinateur si tu veux de samsung qui
prend son téléphone dessus tu pas son
téléphone de sucer du plug and play et
directement tu as un ordinateur règles
pour toi et tu vas voir c'est
passionnant avant de parler des produits
en détail si tu veux ce qui est vraiment
retenir cette présentation c'est que
voilà on a cet écosystème complet tu as
vraiment le développement de la 360
degrés que ce soit en regardant avec ton
téléphone avec telenet vert
avec une nouvelle télécommande qui
permettra de piloter la 360 degrés
est-ce que tu ne pouvais pas faire
avance ne pouvait juste regarder je
dirais là tu vas pouvoir naviguer doit
pouvoir faire beaucoup plus de choses tu
as la caméra 360 degrés justement
d'intégrer du contenu par rapport à ce
casque vert
tu as encore une utilisation je dirais
pour tout est objet connecté au travers
de l'application samsung connecte donc
soit ton frigo ta télé où tout ce que tu
veux
tout va être connecté en un seul et même
endroit donc on est vraiment si tu veux
dans quelque chose de global
on est vraiment dans un écosystème
global samsung et qui est super
intéressant alors parlons d'abord du
téléphone elle suit est celui de plus
deux nouveaux téléphones
je te le disais pas de bordure d'écran
monstrueux avec une puissance de feu
dingue c'est le processeur le plus petit
et pourtant le plus puissant et ce qui
va te permettre en réalité d' économiser
de la batterie d'avoir une longévité
encore plus grande au niveau de la
batterie
c'est un téléphone si tu veux qu'ils
hyper intéressant de se poser la
question est ce qu'on va le
déverrouiller par l'empreinte digitale
est une reconnaissance des richesses qui
a eu de reconnaissance faciale ou est ce
qu'on va pouvoir taper le code comme
avant et ben en réalité il ya les quatre
dedans tu as directement sur ton
téléphone une reconnaissance d'iris dès
que tu le prends en main et tu mets face
à toi tu reconnais ton visage et ça
pourra le déverrouiller automatiquement
ça ira hyper vite derrière au niveau de
la caméra
ils ont gardé l'empreinte digitale pour
un maître ton doigt et le déverrouiller
par l'arrière si tu souhaites
et puis si tu veux garder le
déverrouillage avec le système samsung
tu pourras le faire également tu pourras
faire comme tu veux c'est top
soit vraiment que l'innovation est au
centre de leur stratégie avec google
ils ont vraiment réfléchi à avoir
effectivement en os qui est complètement
en harmonie à noël ce puissant qui va
pouvoir exploiter l'ensemble de la
machine le bouton off devient
complètement invisible il se situe au
niveau de l'écran mais pourtant il est
toujours
bien la torah 5 couleurs tu auras le
midnight black tu auras la couleur
arctique
le modèle gold le koralblue et l'orchid
grecque montre à quoi ça ressemble j'ai
fait une capture d'écran directement
c'est un petit peu flou mais on voit
quand même
les quatre grands moselle situes tu as
vraiment des couleurs hyper élégant très
sympa personnellement le midnight black
j'aime beaucoup la sobriété du douar
très simple toujours j'aime beaucoup de
merci samsung à l'arrière au niveau de
l'appareil photo tu vois aussi un
produit qui va être très très puissant
en terme de qualité photo avec un double
capteur à l'arrière ce qui permettra
d'avoir toujours de dire est la
meilleure photo samsung sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui on partage on fait
beaucoup de photos on est toujours sur
instagram toujours connecté sur les
réseaux sociaux dont ils ont vraiment
optimisé effectivement pour avoir un
appareil photo de la meilleure qualité
qui soit et même la caméra à l'avant
pressel fille n'a pas été négligée
puisqu'elle fait 8 millions de pixels
donc tu aura vraiment une caméra qui
sera d'une excellente qualité pour les
sept filles et d'ailleurs cette arme est
vraiment aussi cette reconnaissance
faciale parce que en réalité il faut
quand même qu'elle puisse bien te
reconnaître sous tous les angles qui
capte bien si la définition des tableaux
ça ne marchera pas autre point
intéressant le samsung s uite est su de
plus on la certification ip68 ce qui
fait tu peux les mettre dans l'eau alors
effectivement tu vas pas non plus aller
au fin fond de l'océan avec des
pressions sous marine de dengue par
contre tu peux les mettre dans l'eau tu
peux aller entre piscine avec il n'y
aura pas de problème ils ont cette
fameuse certification ip68 une recharge
qui se fait aussi par induction
donc tu l'as posera directement sur une
pac d'adduction et sa vache recharger
directement on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
voitures aujourd'hui qui sont équipés de
systèmes de recharge par induction
donc ça devient hyper intéressant
effectivement il ya un point négatif si
tu veux regarder une vidéo tentera de
recharger grâce à toi je dirais de
t'adapter au téléphone alors il faut
prendre là la plaque d'induction avec
toi ben ça c'est toi qui est un peu
chiant mais par contre ça reste quand
même hyper pratique de le prendre une
pause tu ne t'embête plus tu vas plus
temps mettez avec avec des différents
formats de recharge dès que tu as une
zone d'adduction ou du peut recharger un
téléphone tu peut le poser dessus et ça
ça devient hyper pratique notamment se
console gens qui voyagent tous dans des
aéroports où qui ont pas forcément
toujours leurs chargeurs avec eux dès
qu'il ya une zone d'adduction d'eau
zones de recharge qui pose sa recharge
et c'est un gain de temps
abl d'autant plus qu'ils disent vraiment
qu'ils ont mis l'accent sur la sécurité
il ya en tout huit points de contrôle de
sécurité au niveau des batteries donc
vraiment quasiment aucun risque on est
vraiment sur des batteries d'excellente
qualité
d'ailleurs je prépare à garder en ce
moment il ya des spots télé qui tourne
au sujet justement de cette fameuse
sécurité mis en avant par samsung
c'est un téléphone je te disais qui est
connecté pour avoir un écosystème
complet et notamment le vois bien et que
la mise en avant je dirais de plus en
plus de samsung mais ça me saoule paie
sa concurrence avec apple fait avec je
dirais beaucoup de systèmes de paiement
dématérialisé mais ça reste quand même
une vraie avancée technologique d'autant
plus que tu as eu de reconnaissance
faciale ou à l'iris ou à l'empreinte
digitale
donc quoi qu'il se passe toujours un
paiement beaucoup plus rapide et ça
c'est super intéressant c'est une bonne
innovation se retrouvent également
l'application santé de samsung samsung
elle sous alors santé peut-être qu'il
sera traduit directement en français ça
on le verra sa sortie en france en tout
cas toujours est il que tu vas pouvoir
aller encore plus loin au niveau de la
santé au niveau de ta by trees est ce
qu'il y aura une connexion plus tard à
l'avenir avec un médecin
quel sera l'avenir expiré au niveau de
ces objets connectés santé ça on sait
pas encore le toujours est il que
s'offrent myriade de possibilités et
c'est juste passionnant bixby on va
parler de big big bih c'est la nouvelle
intelligence artificielle de samsung
bigby qui à son bouton dédié directement
sur le téléphone
autant le bouton home a disparu autant
maintenant il ya un bain tu peux appuyer
directement pour rejoindre bixby assez
rapidement bixby en réalité fonctionne
de plusieurs manières différentes si tu
veux l'intérêt des glissades qui
comprend le contexte bigbee il va
comprendre ce que tu as enfin programmé
sur ton téléphone il te localise donc
qui sait où tu es donc il arrive à
contextualiser le lieu contextualiser
leur situé dans un restaurant à une
certaine heure il va comprendre que tu
es en train de manger
il va comprendre ce que tu regardes il
va comprendre plein de choses à
comprendre par rapport à ta caméra par
rapport à ce qu'on est en train de
filmer donc on est vraiment sur une
avancée en terme d'intelligence
artificielle et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
tu peux faire plein plein de choses avec
bixby c'est un facilitateur de vie tu
pour envoyer des messages intelligente
dix vivent à comprendre où tu es ce que
tu veux dire il va comprendre plein de
choses et c'est ça qui est intéressant
parce qu'il joue vraiment enfin enrôle
d'intelligence artificielle et pas juste
da
appliquer ce que tu lui dis pense
notamment aux séries qui aujourd'hui
pour l'instant ne fait qu' appliquer ce
que tu dis là il y aura une réelle
compréhension des données du lieu de
leur de plein de choses de plein de
facteurs différents ce qui fait que
voilà on va avoir une vraie avancée
technologique en termes d'intelligence
artificielle
alors après il ya aussi l'application
samsung connect samsung connect c'est
l'application qui va centraliser tous
les objets connectés que la pouvoir
piloter je dirais l'environnement
samsung on pense déjà aux objets de 5
sung au frigo tout ce qui va être en
poule connectés enfin il y en a
énormément une télé un peu quand je
passe un petit peu tout l'environnement
connectés mais tu vas centralisée au
niveau de l'application samsung connect
que tu vas pouvoir aussi piloté par la
voir si tu le souhaites tu vas pouvoir
aller beaucoup plus loin ça va être
extrêmement facile décès la lumière
ouvrir les volets tu pourras y un bon
jour c'est le matin la lumière se met en
place
les volets sous la télé pourquoi pas tu
pourra programmer énormément de choses
et ça va devenir juste hyper simple
l'intérêt tout ça c'est de te simplifier
la vie et de la rendre meilleure
alors il faut savoir que les téléphones
et suite et elle suit plus sorte
officiellement le 21 avril 2010 est pour
les fans de sons et ceux qui aiment
effectivement avoir un bon son et licka
ce qu'il faut savoir qu'un partenariat
qui a été fait avec à kg à cacher je
sais pas si tu connais mais c'est une
excellente marque
une fabrication de microphones mais là
on parle vraiment du casque et les
casques akg âgées sont justes top on
parlait de la vr ya quelques instants
effectivement au niveau de la réalité
virtuelle c'est que samsung a sorti un
casque et une caméra à 360 degrés
l'année dernière
là ils vont encore plus loin en
proposant un petit contrôleur tu auras
la main tu auras ton casque de réalité
virtuelle sur le visage et tu auras ton
contrôleur à la main et tu pourra
contrôler naviguer dedans tu pourras
faire beaucoup plus de choses que tu ne
pouvais pas faire avant et ça devient
juste hyper intéressant tu pourra par
exemple regarder un film en verre
pourquoi pas imagine-toi regarder le
dernier ghost in the shell en vr est
plongé dans l'interaction du film c'est
que sur youtube en plus tu peux publier
des vidéos directement en réalité
virtuelle et donc tu mets ton casse et
tu pourras regarder énormément de vidéos
d'autant plus que avec leur nouvelle
caméra qui vient de sortir à 360° une
caméra qui peut tenir directement la
main avec une poignée et la caméra à 360
degrés dessus ça va permettre encore
plus diversion d'autant plus qu'on a
sont des qualités hyper dingue on les
sort de la 4k
tu pourras le prendre tu le mettras
dessus tu pourra filmer et ensuite tu
vois une petite application sur ton
téléphone qui permettra d'envoyer
directement sur youtube ou sur d'autres
plateformes
imagine toi en train de filmer en live
streaming directement sur youtube en 4k
en verre et des personnes qui te
regardent avec leurs casques de réalité
virtuelle
c'est juste fou imagine-toi regarder la
prochaine qui dote de samsung
directement avec ton casque comme si tu
y étais ça sera juste incroyable
s'adresse vraiment créateurs de contenu
en disant voilà vous vous êtes les
créateurs vous faites du storytelling on
vous donne les outils
prenez nos outils utilisés au mieux et
raconter vos histoires partagées les
dans le monde entier quand vous voulez
comme vous
ce soit apple avec ses produits que ce
soit samsung avec les siens la
technologie crée encore plus d espace de
liberté pour nous permettre de nous
connecter encore plus au monde et de
toujours plus partager nos contenus il
ya eu une grande nouveauté c'est samsung
d'aix alors samsung d'accès quoi c'est
une nouvelle vision de l'ordinateur de
bureau à savoir que samsung d'aix c'est
pas maudite heures un clavier une souris
et je dirais à l'espèce de boîtiers sur
lequel tu va poser ton téléphone
téléphone et reconnus automatiquement et
ce à tous sur le moniteur comme un
ordinateur buron tu navigues avec ton
clavier la souris tu peux envoyer des
mails tu peux édité comme ils l'ont fait
dans la présentation powerpoint
tu peux travailler dessus faire de la
bureautique je sais pas jusqu'où tu peux
aller en terme de puissance par rapport
à ça par rapport à cette machine tu peux
exploiter à fond la puissance de tonton
smartphone pour en faire un vrai
ordinateur de bureau
on imagine toi chez toi si tu es dans un
foyer par exemple toi tosan ou si tu es
une femme toit pour l'époux outils tu
veux ton est plutôt dépouillé enfin peu
importe vous avez chacun à votre samsung
galaxy ace suite vous le prenez vous le
posez vous avez votre session
individualisé ça vous reconnaître
directement reconnaissance faciale ça
délire ou y est vous êtes connecté en un
quart de seconde vous posez vous êtes
connecté dans votre session tu tu
enlèves l'eau de vie avec son téléphone
il est connecté en un quart de seconde
donc plus besoin d'avoir un ordinateur
de maison je dirais avec déverrouiller
mot de passe tac non attends au pape je
reviens il ya un seul poste pour tout le
monde et chacun vient avec son téléphone
et peut l'utiliser à sa guise ça ça
devient hyper intéressante et même dans
les entreprises
imagine-toi par exemple de tarif dans un
aéroport pour les gens qui veulent s
beaucoup il ya un samsung d'aix qui est
posée là tu poses ton téléphone tu
retrouves ta session qui s'est tout
comme chez toi tu par ailleurs sais pas
mais vraiment pour les gens qui
travaillent à dans différents endroits
du juste à voir leurs smartphones et
leurs smartphones c'est tout temps dans
c'est un ordinateur de bureau
c'est à la fois un téléphone portable et
c'est ça qui est super passionnant avec
le nouveau samsung text en réalité
sapent tout dans sa culotte n'a pas
juste présenter son nouveau téléphone
ces nouveaux téléphones
il a présenté sa nouvelle vision du
futur et son nouvel écosystème ce vers
quoi tend samsung la réalité virtuelle
toujours plus de versions toujours plus
de contenus partagés toujours plus de
connectivité
et une collectivité facilité avec des
recharges traduction avec des
ordinateurs pour pouvoir utiliser un peu
partout ce plugin rapidement en réalité
ce que nous propose aujourd'hui ça me
saoule au travers de s'aguerrir c'est
pas juste le dernier smartphone à la
mode ce que nous propose aujourd'hui
samsung
c'est une vision de l'avenir un avenir
plus connectés toujours plus de partage
toujours plus de technologies au service
de ses consommateurs au service de ses
clients
l'acquis note a été menée de main de
maître à la fois dj depuis new york mais
aussi rediffusé directement sur écran
géant à londres il qui nous est
extrêmement intéressante avec un nouveau
téléphone que je ne peux que
t'encourager d'aller voir ses tarifs le
samsung galaxy s litres a vendu à 809
euros et le samsung galaxy s suit plus à
909 euros
côté technologie le et subite c'est un
écran de 5,8 pouces et le s p de plus
6,2 pouces il ya une définition quad hd
2960 par 1440 pixels 64 giga de stockage
un bluetooth 5.0 un port microsd un
grand classique chez samsung
et comme je le disais un appareil photo
de 8 mégapixels à l'avant et de 12
mégapixels à l'arrière et il tournera
sous un android 7
donc voilà aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on
peut dire un petit peu sur ce sont ces
nouveaux sur cette nouvelle ère samsung
on en reparlera très très prochainement
parce qu'on va approfondir le côté digby
on va approfondir le côté de la caméra
360 degrés en 4k on va reparler de la
vère très prochainement on va reparler
de plein de choses
et n'oublions pas que d'ici quelque
temps normalement au mois de juin
apple va faire sa culotte pour parler de
son nouvel iphone donc on va voir ce
qu'ils proposent pour ma part moi qui
suis un très grand fan d'apple je vais
attendre de voir un petit peu ce que
propose apple et voir s'ils arrivent
effectivement avoir une offre qui est
aussi palpitante est aussi intéressante
que celle de samsung parce que on
imagine très bien que aujourd'hui ça
laisse très peu de temps apple de réagir
par rapport à l'annoncé officielle de
samsung
donc on va pas se mettre à créer et à
produire 2
nouvelle offre de nouveaux produits en
appel deux mois serait ce serait ça
serait tellement facile par contre on va
voir si effectivement ils sont dans les
clous il faut quand même avouer que la
samsung a fait quelque chose de très
très fort comme on dit to be continued
si cette vidéo t'intéresser à bonn pour
anna chelle sartre est extrêmement
plaisir on se donne très très très très
bientôt de nouvelles pour une nouvelle
vidéo et d'ici là tu mets tout en
commentaire est une disent que tu en
penses dix mois c'est à regarder la qui
note si tu as regardé oui ou non cette
keynote est ce que cette description
technique t'intéresse qu'est ce que tu
penses de ce nouvel écosystème samsung
est ce que tu as envie de bas à partir
chez samsung est ce que tu as envie
d'acquérir ce nouveau téléphone est ce
que la vr cette part est ce que tu as
envie d'abord cette nouvelle caméra
dis moi tout le monde en parle tu mets
tout en commentaire on reste connectés
et moche de lit à très bientôt
ciao